[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to spectator TV I'm
James heale coming up on today's show
Katie balls and Alex Massey discuss the
resignation of Nicholas sturgeon she
says after eight years in the job she no
longer has the will to keep on going
we'll be discussing that and the likely
contenders to succeed her
is China just a paper dragon Brian
Appleyard writes in this week's magazine
why Chinese science isn't all it's
cracked up to be he'll be joining me and
Cindy you to discuss this further
bird plane spy balloon Andrew
starterford writes in this week's
magazine about America's strange
relationship with the UFOs he'll be
discussing this and the National
Security implications of recent cases
with elridge Colby an expert in the
subject
and finally Kate Andrews writes in this
week's magazine about the toxic Cult of
self-love but it's journaling and waking
up at 3am to shout at yourself in the
mirror really all that bad she'll be
joining me to discuss on the program
before we get going if you do enjoy spit
HTV then subscribe to our YouTube
channel just click the Subscribe button
at the bottom of this video and you'll
never miss another episode
now after sturgeon what's the future for
Scotland and the Union in this week's
magazine Katie Bulls Spectators
political editor looks at the question
of the next Scottish first Minister I'm
joined now to discuss this piece with
Katie and the Scotland spectator Alex
Massey as well Katie why is this
decision and why now
that's a good question James for good
two questions in fact
um I think if we're if we're looking at
you know what are the factors that led
Nick the sturgeon to I think take
the majority by surprise this week
particularly The Spectator as we tried
to put one cover to bed and had to tear
up the whole thing and start again with
two hours to go
um there's so many factors here and I
think it's quite hard to work out right
now and perhaps we'll come clear in the
coming days but the final straw was but
we know Nicola sturgeon has ultimately
seen her grip and her party loosen in
recent months you know she's um under
pressure on several fronts I think
clearly on Independence
um her party uh were beginning to say
particularly those who are the most
passionate about the primary aim of the
Scottish national party and saying when
are we going to get this referendum what
is the route
um obviously last year Nicholas sturgeon
called that referendum that she didn't
have the power to have ended up in a
court battle found that she couldn't do
it and yes it did lead um some s and
people apologies to be able to say once
again Westminster is frustrating the
world the people it also just exposed
how few options she had when it comes to
actually making a referendum happen and
then she went from that to then saying
well it's fine because we're going to
make the general election a de facto
referendum now there are some s p MPS in
Westminster who have had said well are
we really because cost of living was
such a big issue it's just the right
messaging
um are we potentially sacrificial Lambs
on this if we say it's all about this
people talking about something else and
there was a gonna be a conference coming
up where this would have to be decided
and it has speech the sturgeon reference
is saying I can't go to this conference
if I'm not sure I'm going to see it all
the way through now Nicholas sturgeon
was very keen short about the personal
toll being in a Frontline politics role
has had
um there were I think more than a few
parallels we're just into Arden and New
Zealand primary he recently resigned
herself but
to say when you speak to you know
figures within the s p but also Scottish
pods and Westminster and who thinks more
perceived other precious facing her
because away from Independence we also
had obviously the route over the gender
recognition bill and the fact that
Nicholas sturgeon pushed that forward
device within her party and then you had
Richard Cena block it uh Nicola sturgeon
and I said well this is ultimately a
Tory prime minister waging a culture War
but it turns out more Scots are not seem
to agree with Russia Riley Nicholas
sturgeon but polling suggests that was
backed and then I think when that then
became a scandal involving rapist in
female prisons in Scotland it clearly um
escalated further and that was really
difficult for her you also have
questions about alone and involving her
husband you have ongoing situation with
Alex salmond which is upset Southern s p
party
um and then you have scanned social the
ferry and you have the domestic record
and that all comes together and I think
you just have a prime and you have a
first Minister he was under a lot of
pressure and when you look at that
Jacinda Arden compared person and was
this a leader who you know Supreme new
popular lots of politician looked on
with envy and he just decided it was all
too much it wasn't a leader who
effectively was just going before things
got a lot worse for both themselves and
their party and perhaps they were pushed
Alex in this week's magazine Katie talks
about how Nicholas sturgeon's domestic
record was perhaps Ketch came up with
her you write in the times today talking
about how you know she didn't deliver on
health or education compared to the
aspirations she had is there a sense
perhaps that she'd frankly run out of
the road
yes but that is much more as Casey says
I think um running out of road on the
Constitutional question rather than uh
her a domestic agenda I mean it's true
Nicholas dungeon once said you know I
want to be judged on my record on
education but that was always that
struck me as a as a profoundly cynical
type of uh declaration because a
politician who says they want to be
judged on a an issue where they're
unlikely to make significant progress in
the short term is one who's saying that
knowing uh secure in the knowledge that
they won't be uh judged on their record
by their most devoted supporters you
know because the you know the the SNP
uh has a lot of Voters who for instance
say you know say if you're a teacher
um and you vote SMP if you were to judge
them purely on their record on education
you you know they might not vote SNP but
they believe in Independence and that is
the more important thing
um and if you believe in Independence
well where else can you go really if you
consider this to be the most important
uh subject in Scottish politics um so
that the SMP has a very very high floor
uh for its support if you like
um and the you know sturgeon is able to
capitalize on that so that's the
questions about education or drugs or
even even the gender stuff doesn't
really necessarily have that much of an
impact
um so the problem for her was running
out of road on the Constitution and I
think it's very important to note that
it isn't the British government and it
isn't the Supreme Court that is
effectively blocking a secondary
Independence referendum it's the people
of Scotland who are doing so if it was
clear that 60 65 70 of Voters in
Scotland demanded a referendum I think
it would be almost impossible for the
not to be one and the moral and
political case for that would be pretty
much unanswerable as of course was the
case in 2011 when the SMP won a majority
in the Scottish Parliament and everybody
agreed including the political parties
who didn't want that to be a referendum
but it was reasonable for them to be one
and it's that test of reasonableness
that at present the SMP struggles to
pass
um now in the longer term you can
envisage circumstances in in which
Scottish voters begin to think it is
more reasonable to have a referendum
than not but at present uh that is not
where they are and so it's the people
who are blocking the road to a
referendum and so you have this sort of
bitterly ironic situation in which it is
plausible or possible to argue that it
might be easier for the SMP to win a
referendum on Independence than it is
for them to get a referendum on
Independence and so you know that is the
the if you like the Strategic problem
Nicola sturgeon faced
um and one that she was unable to to
answer frankly you know she has spent
the last six years promising every six
months uh that there would be another
push for Independence marching her
troops up to the top of the mountain
only to then March them back down and
after a while even even the credulous
ones begin to answer you begin to ask
well you know what are we doing here why
aren't we actually making any real
progress
um uh and that is the the problem and
and that's the one that any new leader
any successes in liquor sturgeon is
going to have to confront and find an
answer
um but if Nicholas sturgeon couldn't
find an answer to this problem you do
have to wonder how well equipped any of
her potential successes will be to find
an answer to the same issues that
stymied Nicholas sturgeon Alex mentions
the question there of succession who are
the likely candidates so I think it is
Testament to how much space Nicola
sturgeon has occupied in politics that
there isn't really an obvious successor
so there's lots of you know you have
bookies favorites you have some lots of
people saying you know
are they interested in running
um but there's not an obvious error
apparent
um and therefore when I think you're
looking at potential Runners and Riders
so for example the book is favorite when
this was announced was Angus Robertson
um who of course used to be an MP before
he lost his seat Douglas Ross the lead
of Scottish conservatives now an MSP and
when he was in Parliament he was the SMP
Westminster leader and I think he's a
you know pro-eu squash nationalist uh
confidence speaker and that has seen as
someone who would be a relatively safe
Pair of Hands then you have Kate Forbes
I think there's quite a lot of excited
chatter about Cape Forbes has long been
a rising star within the SMP and her
role as Finance Minister and she has
been on maternity leave lately
um and she is someone who I think is
seen as someone who could probably uh
continue a lot of Nicholas sturgeon did
um and since she was a close Ally but
would be different in some ways and
there's one thing already with uh Kate
Forbes which is she is a committed
Christian so you're already hearing some
say well how would that impact her if
she was to be the leader of the SMP
because we know that the party is taking
you know a really Progressive stance and
lots of social issues and we talk about
the gender recognition bill but also um
would you have a Tim Ferrin problem when
you have you know a leader who leads a
party which is pretty liberal in its
value socially and again every interview
comes back to you what are your personal
views however on gay marriage what are
your personal views on abortion and it
makes it really hard to move past and I
think it's perhaps a sign of the way the
race is going if you're already saying
that and suggests that she is perhaps
one to beat
um and then I you can go through you
know there's there's more uh you know
candidates
um for example Johannes Cherry's name
will often come up with Scottish Tories
but I think a she obviously isn't um in
currently in a position to um go for it
and also she did Clash of many over the
gender recognition Bill and you have the
ultimately the SMP secretary
you end up in a situation where I think
we can talk about names but as of yet no
one has yet to declare so there's a case
of who wants a role
um and then and then William get the
support
um Alex can you imagine a really
interesting question there which is
there's lots of names we can talk about
but actually if you look at the history
of the SMP there's not really a history
of contested elections they're typically
won by two-thirds of the vote by one
clear favorite do you think we're going
to have a really kind of contested
election and second of all do you think
we're going to see the Constitutional
question and the differences in approach
about how to approach um uh Independence
rear its head and really dominate what
do you think are going to be the key
issues in any race should one occur well
quite a lot will I think depend on the
terms and conditions the rules that are
and the timetable that is set for an
election
um there is obviously certain uh there's
a there's an argument in favor of
getting it done quickly
um if that were to happen uh over the
next month or so then I think one would
have to presume that would favor any
candidate that begins with a higher than
normal uh rated name recognition so
you'd be talking about a John Sweeney or
an Angus Robinson maybe a cape Forbes uh
if it's a longer more protracted process
then that obviously provides greater
opportunity for Less well-known names
such as Neil gray uh junior minister in
tollywood
um or some other you know candidate who
is effectively unknown to the general
public and and that again you know just
to sort of reiterate some of the
problems and so on there's been a lack
of clear succession planning from Nicola
sturgeon uh and it is impossible to
imagine that any of her successors can
have quite the same uh breadth and depth
of connection to the average of typical
Scottish voter as Nicola sturgeon had
um and yes I would expect that because
this is a contest to that will be
decided by party members
uh not the general public the the
approach to the Constitutional question
which is after all the the smps only
non-negotiable policy it's foundational
reason for existence is going to
dominate and therefore
um there is an incentive in certain
respects for candidates to
tell the party what it wants to hear
which isn't necessarily the same as what
the party can deliver and so the Hoops
that you have to jump through to win the
leadership election are Hoops that may
end up being traps for you once you're
actually in office yourself
um because you will have made
commitments that it is not necessarily
obvious you are in a position to honor
and so I think they have to be very wary
of that
um and you you know but the s p is such
a dominant party in Scotland that you
know you don't act you can win elections
um without having to seek to persuade
anyone who isn't already an s p a
committed SNP supporter
um you don't actually have to reach
across political divides you don't have
to have a big tent a big Scotland um uh
type approach you can just win an
election by appealing to the SMP Rank
and file and its core support but that
doesn't help you get to the 50 threshold
that one day you need for Independence
um and so the SMP is trapped in in this
situation where it is relatively easy
for them to continue to dominate
Scottish politics with 40 of the vote 45
of the vote but getting that you know
those final few percentage points of
support which is what they require in
the longer term becomes very much more
difficult and what works for the base
the party membership may not be what is
required for the general public
um that you need to appeal to uh in uh
any putative Independence referendum but
again the road to that referendum is not
clear and I don't really see how any new
leader can take an approach that is
obviously different from Nicholas
sturgeon while at the same time wanting
to serve if you're like honor her uh her
memory
um uh and so the SNP is at a very
difficult position I think actually you
know
um a genuine set of choices that have to
be made but all of them are fairly
speculative and none of them carry with
any guarantee or even possibly any
likelihood of paying off in the
short-term
Alex I mean Nico sturgeon may have
failed to get independence but she came
top of every single Westminster and
Hollywood election for the best part of
a decade what do you think her Legacy is
likely to be
well uh I suppose
um taking a longer term view if say in
10 years time uh Scotland has become an
independent state then I think Nicholas
stegan surgeon's Legacy would be that of
if you like the the founding mother who
made that possible in many respects
along with obviously Alex salmond
um uh if however that doesn't happen
then I think her Legacy is
very much diminished
um because you know you can't point to
that many
um
notable achievements in areas of default
responsibility there are a couple I
think the setting up of new Social
Security Service
um in Scotland and the creation of a
dedicated child benefit payment Scottish
child payment which costs around 500
million plans a year
um as paid to poorer families I think
that you know but when you move beyond
that to areas like health and education
drugs transport the record is very much
more mixed
um so at a core fundamental level
perhaps the
um the True Legacy is that Independence
is a
as a possibility as a concept has been
thoroughly normalized
um it is if it was ever Unthinkable it
no longer is it's entirely thinkable
um and so that is then the basis upon
which all future Scottish politics will
be based uh for the foreseeable future
a fascinating question one which we will
continue to discuss on spectator TV
thank you Alex thank you Katie
now flights are fancy how UFOs captured
the imagination of America and the world
and this week's magazine Andrew
stutterford talks about how the recent
Chinese spy balloons are part of a wider
phenomena dating back to the 19th
century uh Andrew first of all welcome
uh thank you for joining us on spectator
TV talk us through all these sort of
suspected UFO sightings uh since this
trend first began and how they sort of
occur in sort of Trends it's called you
call them flaps and that's the name for
them tell us about this piece and how
UFOs became such a huge American
cultural phenomena
certainly uh I mean you have UF UFOs um
have been around for a long time you you
there are you know there are cases uh in
the Middle Ages uh and before that
um but what change what changed things
uh that was uh mass communication and uh
the first uh UFO flap although they
didn't use the term then
um was uh in the in the 1890s uh in um
California uh when people saw uh various
forms of allegedly saw various forms of
uh uh of um airships some with wings
great size some containing martians uh
it's not better than anyone ever saw
anything uh even a hallucination
um but the stories spread and uh and
that was really a Proto flap if you like
um it was forgotten
um but what you so what what you saw uh
in the in the years that followed was uh
what I think of as an intellectual
softening up for the idea that UFOs
might be real and that came from two two
sides which sort of in some ways merged
the first was that you you saw um uh
science moving forward uh you you had uh
gone out in the U.S uh was actually
um shooting off Rockets liquid fuel uh
rockets in in I think 1926 if I remember
was the first one and uh and then and
there were other people the Russians had
I hadn't set anything off at that point
but they were working on it uh and then
of course the Germans in the early 30s
and um so there was the scientific
possibility of space travels was
becoming real
um at the same time the fictional uh
parameters were
had expanded I think partly because of
the way the science was again you can go
back a long long time to find references
to beings on on other planets
um but uh then you had HD Wells with the
uh The War of the Worlds and um but in
the 20 and you you did see sort of
magazines which had science fiction
stories in the Edwardian era in a bit
later but in the 20 but in the 20s you
you began to see particularly in the U.S
uh pulp sci-fi which became
um the quality went up and up and up but
all the people like Asimov and so on
they all began there and um so come
World War II
you have
um again leaps forward in science there
were odd reports the so-called Foo
Fighters which were uh reported by
almost all the competent Airmen on not
all Governor uh Ireland from all sides
these strange balls of light
um and that went made it to Time
Magazine but the real moment was
um in 1947 when uh Kenneth Arnold who
was a businessman
he was taking his plane uh past Mount
Rainier in Washington state and he saw
quote uh nine nine uh bright objects and
uh when he came back uh to the base he
bet he mentioned that he'd seen that and
uh he said
as a lot of debate over what he actually
said but he he he he he he probably said
they skipped across like sources and the
phrase saucer caught the imagination he
he he probably never described them as a
sources change
um but that's what caught the
imagination and again you had mass media
and
um within within within days uh everyone
was talking about either flying discs or
flying sources and
um the uh the the Roswell crash uh which
wasn't really what was described as uh
that followed a couple of weeks later
but all over the country there were
sightings of alleged sightings of UFOs
and you also that in turn got the media
interesting the media report you know a
UFO story sold very well but then the
fictional side of uh also got interested
and it wasn't just there was the Sci-Fi
of course which carried on and was
carrying on but you also got as the
decade went on uh you also got Hollywood
interested so you had basically a Fusion
on the ones that you had a fusion
between
science and or or perceptions of Science
and fiction and on the other side you
had all these stories floating around be
promoted by the media those stories
intent in turn were then reflected by
the media and then reflected back and
they shaped what people saw and so the
UFO narrative began
that's fascinating and joining us is
Eldritch Colby and Andrew and his piece
writes that uh you know the census that
scan America's Skies have been
recalibrated to catch slower moving
items such as these suspicious Chinese
balloon
um explain to us why these items were
shot down there were four items we
believe and um just about the context of
why the American Military is involved
with uh UFOs and the real life threats
we face
well I'll defer to Andrew and others on
on the sort of UFO phenomenon for those
who are I mean there's his very good
piece coming out in The Spectator but uh
my friend Tom Rogan wrote a piece in the
Washington examiner kind of looking at
the issue I'd commend people's attention
I thought very kind of thoughtful and
empirical
um just in terms of the the Chinese
balloon and the three additional
balloons that or objects I should say
that have been downed I mean the initial
balloon a very large shiny surveillance
balloon that Transit the United States
and Canada that was clearly a Chinese
surveillance balloon three additional
objects have been identified what's what
appears to have happened listening to
people like General van hurke the
commander of Northern command NORAD and
others
um is basically the United States is
somehow uh gleaned a little while ago or
some time ago that there were objects
that were coming into our our
territorial airspace or surroundings
that were potentially uh maligned to use
the term frequently frequently employed
by the US government
um you know intelligence and
surveillance these kinds of things and
so and then we we determined that we had
missed some of them so so the three
um balloon transits that the
Administration has indicated happen
under the Trump Administration my
understanding is that we did not
determine that that had happened until
afterward
um and you know also the transit was it
seems like it was much more modest so
the the the balloon that came over uh a
week and a half or so ago that was a
much more significant one what we've
done is we've basically uh made our
sensors as far as I can tell much more
sensitive so much more likely to pick up
a wider range or I should say kind of a
smaller items or slower moving items if
you will and of course that's radar
um that's overhead reconnaissance that
may be um that maybe other sensors and
you know with the the big data and AI we
can process in a much more information
than we used to so traditional challenge
for the intelligence gathering
Enterprise has always been uh the
exploitation of information that's
gleaned because if you have to do it by
hand or eye there's Stark limitations
and now with computers we can do in Big
Data AI et cetera we can do a lot more
so I think as of now we don't know what
those three objects where the American
government says it does not know two of
them are in the arc near the Arctic
Circle one is in like here on which is a
very large great lake so the the
Administration has said they're benign
um they they seem to have think they
have evidence for that we'll have to
wait and see but that's where things
stand right now
you talk about the Chinese surveillance
balloon I mean is this something that
we're going to see more of do you think
in the future
um in terms of sort of China testing
seeing what is possible to sort of get
away with a bit like we've seen in the
UK you know in a different context a
Russians the Russian Jets entering
British airspace to kind of test resolve
Etc do you think we're going to see more
of these kind of surveillance balloons
as an issue uh in the future and
learning how to sort of live with them
and cope with them and deal with them as
threats well almost certainly I mean one
point is that they have been uh
transiting I mean Japan uh the
Philippines
um certainly Taiwan itself but other
India uh US government has indicated
that the Chinese have used balloons in
all of those locations and possibly more
there was another Chinese surveillance
balloon that was operating over Central
America
so absolutely no question I mean nothing
is certain in this world but as certain
as we can be there's a very large
Chinese surveillance and intelligence
gathering program and a very
increasingly Global Chinese military
they're looking at basing I mean even an
Equatorial Guinea on the Atlantic coast
of Africa a year or so ago not to
mention the Middle East East Africa the
Indian Ocean South Pacific Chinese
fishing vessels which are pretty large
when especially when they're guarded by
Maritime militia we're operating
aggressively off the Galapagos recently
so I think without question we're going
to all be feeling uh the the sort of
pressure from uh greater Chinese
intelligence and ultimately military
operations going forward and Andrew I
mean I wanted to sort of tease out this
out as a question really I mean what is
the kind of relationship between UFOs
and discussions and sightings around
that in terms of sort of military
context I'm thinking about the sort of
space race of the the 1950s and 60s
really
um how what is the relationship like
between unidentified flying objects and
the relationship with what's going on in
military context as well
I think I think it's fairly
way you can see the UFO
um at least Mains this answer this is a
really weird phrase you but mainstream
UFO Community uh is is is is clearly
reflects uh what is what what is going
on in the outside world and that clearly
has in the past and I think currently
actually has included defense issues I
mean if you look at uh the you know the
first great flap uh which really lasted
throughout the rest of the 1940s and
there was one over Washington uh in as
late as 5152
and which which worried even um Harry
Truman
um the the the I think they were a
firstly there was an awareness that
danger could come from overhead the V2s
had made that point
and then uh as they looked at the
increasing Soviet threat particularly
after uh uh especially since it got
nuclear and so on there was an unease
and attention and that I think partly
found expression through uh through
through
UFOs uh were that were they were they
looking at
um
the Russians or were they looking at
something from elsewhere and indeed the
um CIA and this again makes one sound
like a conspiracy theorist uh it was it
was very interesting that the the origin
the the initially the the U.S
government military slash military
authorities
um uh wanted to down talk with the UFO
as there was the magnificently named uh
project Grudge uh which which was
designed to basically debunk it because
they thought they were bad for morale
um but then later on and I don't know
the exact dates at all whether the 60s
or 70s uh but people when a lot of those
very Advanced spy planes uh the black
birds of this world uh were were flying
around uh Pilots would see them and the
CIA would use all sorts of explanations
I believe including UFOs to or hinting
at UFOs to take away attention from the
fact that this was in fact American
Advanced Weaponry being being tried and
you know let's not talk about Area 51
but you can go into all sorts of
discussions as to that's quite useful
disinformation Flash Forward uh to um
today
um and well if you go to the 90s there
there you had paranoia but but that
wasn't really so much to do with defense
uh and the X-Files and all that but if
you flash forward to today we are
clearly in the middle of a UFO flap
which is directly uh related to what the
Chinese
um have been doing because as a as
someone fascinated by UFOs with a
lifelong skeptic I I saw some of these
images of the so-called Tic Tacs uh
which are these little white things that
that have been photographed uh by pilots
I heard what the pilots had to say was
very much in the news over here
and
um that really has given a a fresh
impetus to Classic UFO sighting this
wasn't something spiritual this was here
we are here we have things that people
are seeing pilots who are always seen as
extremely reliable and it does seem now
that there's I've seen people still
saying there's questions about what was
seen from the Nimitz in I think 2004 but
a lot of the things that have been seen
are in reality
um Chinese balloons or Chinese drones
um we we shouldn't forget the drones uh
uh as if I could uh the the the the the
the the a lot of the weird movements you
might have seen in some of the reports
or the or or even some of the footage
might be uh drones uh Chinese drones
which have apparently been reported near
American ships and so on
well fascinating discussion and want to
keep an eye on uh thank you very much
Eldridge thank you Andrew
now Paper Dragons is Chinese science all
it's cracked up to be discussing this
topic are Cindy from The Spectator and
Brian athletart who writes for this
week's Magazine on why China might be a
great imitator but not necessarily a
great innovator Brian explain to us your
thesis in this week's magazine
I think China has a lot of catching up
to do and
um because it it actually didn't Embrace
science really until the early 20th
century
um and even then it was a bit reluctant
I mean dencia ping said thought is
better than uh actually it's better than
thought which is not necessarily true in
science and perhaps that's what it is I
don't know but the other thing is that
they
were a relatively poor country for a
long time and didn't have the
um equipment I mean the the Chinese
um military uh Power now is very much
dependent on the fact that it's been
made it's made itself very rich and um
so I think it's just a sort of drag
effect and they have had to rethink
um
their philosophy of of how things are
done and I think War losses in the 19th
century and so on made them realize the
West had something they didn't have and
that was science really
let's see how accurate is that sort of
reflection of China's development and
intellectual thought and the kind of
philosophy underpinning a lot of the
Chinese state and its role towards
technology over the past 100 years or so
yeah yeah I mean Brian is right that we
often forget that China was a very poor
country until very very recently I mean
the way we talk about China now in the
last few weeks a spy balloon story makes
it seem as if it's the next techno
superpower and it could well be but as
Brian says we're not there yet and if
you look at China's recent history you
know it was very much like a pre-opening
up Japan in a sense that there were so
many hundreds of years of just feudalism
closing off the rest of the world really
not developing domestically and focusing
more on the classical literature when
you're you're going for your exams or
you're going for the bureaucracy you're
valued on how much how many confusion
rights you know rather than whether or
not you can have some kind of inline
event value of experimentation so I
think all of that contributed to a
situation where by the end of the 19th
century China's technology just wasn't
on a par with the west and that had very
real geopolitical impact on China and
its people and so over the last 100
years China has really looked into this
idea of science saving the nation and I
think that's why that's made such huge
strides I mean Brian is right we're
still very very behind in China when it
comes to science but it's made really
really rapid strides there in the last
100 years and I think it'll be
interesting to see whether or not that
speed continues in the next let's say
100 years and whether or not that means
an overtaking by then and there's been a
real priority for presidency as well yes
absolutely
in China 2025 which is basically moving
away from China as a toy factory of the
world a clothes Factory of the world
into semiconductors smartphones uh
renewable energy all of these things
that China is making Headway in
um make success for example with
semiconductors it just doesn't do as
well as Taiwan a country with much less
investment of much smaller scale so
they'll make success there but for
seasoning ping is a very much a top
priority as well
um but I think you know the overriding
message from Brian's piece which is a
hysteria that we sometimes have about
Chinese Tech is sometimes misplaced but
also that doesn't mean writing it off
completely yeah Brian in the magazine
you write about the difficulty in trying
to get an accurate sense of where China
is and all of that obviously you said
that part of you know Season success is
if the reporting is taken at face value
about some of the claims about Chinese
military Paris there's obviously
difficulties in reporting on China and
sort of what's been going on as sort of
the extent of their Innovation there I I
just wondered you know how can we best
get an accurate sense of where China is
via V America and the West at the moment
um
shorter entries I don't know because the
problem is there's a sort of desperation
about China at the moment which is
producing
horrific
um
abuses of science I mean those that the
man who produced Gene edited babies you
know suddenly out of the blue he did it
he did it he achieved it whether what
the effect wasn't those babies will be
is unknown but he was he was thrown into
prison because the Chinese realized this
was an embarrassment to them I mean it
was against the law what he did but they
realized it was against the
international law as well it was an
embarrassment to do it
um and and the
um I noticed the the there's a Chinese
fighter plane which looks remarkably
like uh the F-22 Raptor of the Americans
so there is this sense that they're
imitating and actually it was the F-22
Raptor that shot down the balloon
ironically but
um I don't know that we can know I mean
obviously American intelligence will
know so much that you know we don't know
so it's impossible to tell but there is
this sense in which things like the
quantum computer claim made in China
which
everybody else in the world has said is
is just outrageously wrong
um which is lucky because I didn't want
my bank account cleaned out tomorrow
which it could have done if it worked
um then
um you know it's noise it's noise so it
makes it difficult to know what's true
and what's not
um and I mean Cindy I mean this whole
point about you know China being you
know an imitator rather than an
innovator I mean this is sort of classic
what we see with every sort of great
power over the years you know over the
centuries you know they all try and
learn from each other
um I just wanted it that's a sort of is
that changing at all in recent years of
postcovid um in terms of what China is
trying to obviously you mentioned the
strategy earlier um but it's something
that's both similar in military spheres
as well as civilian or is it sort of
particularly focused in one area at all
well I think one interesting thing about
the Russian invasion is how much it
exposed the Russian army as being
actually quite derelict and out of date
and possibly you know open question over
how good the Western armies are as well
but you know I think for China actually
in the military sense there is a lot of
stuff that is from Soviet Legacy as well
and I think that if they were to invade
Taiwan we would see how much of that is
similar to the Russian army when it
comes to being paper tigers
um and then when it comes to you know
what Brian's point about digging
themselves up if I may you know the
social credit scheme something that has
talked about so often in the west and
uses a bogeyman so often as well it's
actually one of those instances too
where Chinese PR was much more
um dramatic and fun and exciting about
it this kind of notion of a Black Mirror
score but it actually doesn't exist like
that in China actually I mean it exists
in a completely different way that you
wouldn't even recognize it there was no
single school that Chinese people live
by that's dealt with by facial
recognition all of this stuff a lot of
it is advertising from often local
governments or just government sources
to make themselves look like they're
very technologically advanced and we do
ourselves as a service when we kind of
buy into that and then make policy based
on that which in the last few years we
have done one of the points you try to
stress in the piece is that one of the
few areas perhaps the only area in which
there's bipartisan corporation on in
Washington between Republicans and
Democrats is this need to sort of curb
the rise of China and counter that do
you think that with these points about
sort of China trying to overtake America
in various spheres this is going to be a
real priority for America and thus the
West in the years to come and what
really more can be done to curb these
kind of behaviors
well
um I think it's difficult to tell
because I mean China's response is
always say no it's not a like it's not a
it's a weather balloon or you know we
didn't do it Americans did it and so on
which so it's like with Putin there's
all this noise of
statement and denial
um I think we have to think I mean it's
unfortunate that we have to think this
way
because there's no reason to to mourn
the fact that China's become a rich
successful country on the face of it
it's just that they have decided
um well I'm sure we've all decided that
they are they are the enemy of the West
and they they resent the West just as uh
Putin does
um now you can't unpick that
so once you know one breach of the of
the deal and everybody goes back into
overdrive which is what's happening now
um so like how you would do that I don't
know I mean there may be a common cause
that we could unite around
um which everybody assumes is the
environment but I don't think that's
going to happen somehow it's I mean
China's not really interested it's built
it's digging coal mines and so on so
um I don't know I think I think there's
something worth saying on top of that
which is just after I wrote this piece I
was speaking to a scientist and he's he
said
think about Chinese science is that you
can look at certain areas like astronomy
where they're really good I mean you
know in the bit among the best in the
world and these these are non-military
things I mean space may be a military
thing but it's not necessarily and
um astronomy is certainly a very
important area very um the very well
well financed there in China now
I think that's wonderful to hear I mean
I'm delighted if Chinese do very good
astronomy because you know I love
hearing about astronomy but um whether
um so that's just to say that Chinese
science pure science is brilliant we
know that it may be brilliant on the way
to the quantum computers which is
potentially a weapon let's face it and
but you know it could be a weapon if
America got there first but
um uh it it's just sad that we have to
talk about there's a having replaced one
gargantuan enemy in Russia
um we're now replacing with China which
just strikes me as sad and it's The
Human Condition really isn't it
Cindy one of the points the brah makes
the piece is about um the cover vaccines
which China tried to develop has that
kind of taken an effect on China's own
self-esteem about the image about China
as an innovator great science superpower
on all these issues or is it not made
any effect whatsoever no I think it
definitely has actually and I think
that's one of the reasons that the party
took so long to overturn zero covert
because you know part of made in China
2025 is to be good at life sciences and
that means vaccines and when the biggest
pandemic the world has ever seen in over
100 years comes along you can't create
your good vac your domestic vaccines are
as good as the Western ones well that is
a slap in the face to people in Beijing
I'm not sure your average Chinese person
thinks about it in such nationalistic
ways but they have been made to suffer
the consequences of that embarrassment
at the top because they were made to go
through lockdowns instead of mass
vaccinations or mass vaccinations of
mRNA vaccines vaccines which China
doesn't yet have and so I think all of
that kind of just shows the leadership
oh actually we're not as good at science
as we thought we were
um
we still have to be a bit more you know
working hard over that but I think that
actually leads to a lot of defensiveness
in this current iteration of the Chinese
Communist party where where they're
lashing out the wolf Warrior thing is
coming out because they think that the
zero cover thing will stay for so long
because they think we have to defend
ourselves against accusations that we're
not as good at science well actually it
just makes it look even more
embarrassing in the long run well that's
what I was going to ask you for my next
question was going to be you know are
there going to be concrete steps that we
can see being taken already to try to
close that Gap you know America remember
obviously in the 1560s refer to the
missile Gap and there was a sort of way
of trying to make that about a more
militaristic element or is this still
the regime in China still lashing out on
defensiveness rather than kind of
seriously sobering considering you know
there is a lot of money going into
science right now so in the last few
years what we've seen is basically a
clamp down on consumer Technologies so
for example things like Alibaba Didi
schulzing which is Chinese Uber all of
these things in like a gig economy that
had been thriving in the early 10 2010s
in China were clamped down on instead
the government focus on more state-led
technology so we're talking about
semiconductors Life Sciences as we've
mentioned Renewables as well billions of
dollars are going into these areas and
semiconductors is going to be the
hottest composition coming up because
the Americans have done something called
the chips act which means that it's
basically pressuring the world to choose
between Chinese and American Supply
chains and China doesn't want that
because they're semiconductors go into a
lot of the different demands around the
world so at the moment we have a very
globalized supply chain about this but
the Americans are trying to decouple and
force Chinese out and the Chinese are
saying well you know actually we've got
to be vital in this process and so a lot
of money is going to that and I think it
will be much like a Cold War era Tech
race I I hear what Brian's saying about
how sad it is that we have to draw
border National borders of in science
because I mean it's good for Humanity
for any of this development to be done
at the same time I do wonder how much
competition geopolitical competition
does also Drive scientific progress as
we saw in the Cold War and Brian I mean
a few years I remember there was a
specific test paper talking about the
kind of technology that has feared that
British academics were helping to
develop in China which could be used for
military purposes there's obviously been
talk about personnel as well I just
wonder what Britain's role in all of
this is um are we frankly you know
involved in this kind of discussions uh
even as a minor player or really will it
just be set between America and China as
we've seen with things like the chips
Act
yeah I think
I mean there's another there's another
point which is that whether we like it
or not the Chinese are already in our
heads
um via Tick Tock and so on and um that
and then and um Huawei I think um
they've got sort of um
dimensions of observation on us and uh
God knows what how much Tick Tock uh
sucks up
um so
I think I think we are if I mean there
was a big round about Huawei and the um
the 5G system and we termed against them
but you see this is going to be these
are going to be rounds that shouldn't be
there because
um why I mean if China didn't think in
terms of uh using Huawei as a spy system
as they probably do Tick Tock if they
didn't think like that it wouldn't
matter that we shared these things and
it would be better for all of us but you
know I'm being ludicrously simple-minded
there
um but I think um the British
have in certain areas what are the some
of the best science in the world and the
Chinese know this
um as I said astronomy which we're also
very good at
um so if it you know I think we will be
sucked into a Chinese comp Chinese
competition in good areas and bad
um and um
we've got to see our way through that
I'm not you know I can't tell you what
the British are going to do I don't know
I would come to imagine
um about the British scientists working
in China and doubt is pretty scientist
working China do but get put on
um Brian I just want to challenge that
view a little bit of the fact that it's
the Chinese thinking about technology as
a kind of national weapon that's leading
us to the situation I think the
Americans absolutely do that too and
that's the way they have maintained
their superpower status throughout the
last few decades you know I mean when it
comes to Huawei we already now have
Insider accounts that it was very much
the American State Department that was
pressurizing the UK into cutting Huawei
out of our systems at a time when there
was actually no explicit evidence that
Huawei was being used as a spy system so
I just think you know geopolitics is as
you say is not simple but I also don't
think that when we're in this bipolar
era that won't you know I guess it and
what I'm saying is that it takes two to
tango that's not a challenge I'm 50 50.
I mean you know of course America's
doing those things
um I happen to prefer to live in the
west than in China so I'll just say you
know China's doing those things I'm on
the side of of the west but it I
acknowed America's doing those things
and some of them are probably awful but
you know of course I was only talking
about China well thank you Brian for a
fantastic piece in this week's magazine
and thank you Cindy for joining us as
well and lastly Kate Andrews writes for
this week's magazine about the toxic
Cult of self-love Kate welcome to the
program what is what exactly is the
toxic health of self-love
um well it's perhaps more an observation
than an official title I don't think
anybody practicing what I write about
this week would label themselves in the
toxic Cults of self-love
um but I've noticed that I think in a
reasonable backlash to say the body
shaming and the stigmatization of mental
health in the decades past there has
been now perhaps an over correction in
the way that we view self-love
um rather than just focusing on it and
being kinder to ourselves and more
forgiving of ourselves there does seem
to be quite a lot of people out there a
lot of individuals a lot of corporates a
lot of messaging that now it's all about
you
um and actually if you start just
seeking out ways to be a bit nicer to
yourself you can easily become quite
exhausted you have to love yourself
apparently all the time without fail no
excuses no questions and I write this
week that I actually think that that
kind of self-focus not only is it a bit
narcissistic but it can really just
drive you to misery and to research this
piece you undertook a fair amount of
your own sort of investigative
journalism looking at a lot of tick-tock
accounts what did you come across when
you were studying all of them that's a
really kind way to talk about me just
wasting time on Tick Tock because I
would love to pretend that I was seeking
this out but actually I just found it
which is kind of what inspired the piece
but um I was most struck by the 5 a.m
risers and I described them as usually
women across age spans they might be at
University right now they might be
Millennial women sort of the girl boss
type they might be mothers with multiple
kids who are waking up at 5am although
as I discovered in some cases they're
pushing it back to 4am even 3 A.M to
basically have a day before they have
their day and I suppose it's just coming
late to the 5 a.m Club but they've
turned the 5 a.m Club into a very
extreme activity so it's not that you
exercise for 20 minutes it's that you
get your 90 minute workout in it's not
that you have breakfast it's that you
have you drink your greens and you eat
your pre-made breakfast that you prepped
on the Sunday and they spend hours and
and doing all this and all of it's
supposed to be in the name of self-love
um and you know I I find that exhausting
I'm tired enough when I have jet lag and
I'm up at 5am let alone thinking that
you just have to have it's about
consistency it's like this pure
consistency and I wonder if some of this
is displacing anxious Behavior anxious
feeling into something that they can
Rebrand is healthy but again I think a
lot of it is you know actually people
are looking for these answers sometimes
times it doesn't feel like there's a lot
of love in the world self-love is really
hard
um and yet they're coming up with these
routines almost as a replacement for
like accepting their flaws and I I don't
know I'm I'm not convinced by it yes I
was wondering if that self-love has just
made a displacement activity sort of
searching for something else rather than
you know in a quite Hollow existence
perhaps is that the case you're sort of
finding is that it's often people you
know maybe younger people and how much
of an extent is this a female phenomenon
as well I mean I notice primarily women
but then I have to note that the
algorithm is probably showing me that
content
thinking that I'm
like to do this too and like for the
record I don't I actually talk about how
in the piece I I did try some of the
affirmations that you're supposed to do
so how'd you find those well you're
supposed to take like a good chunk of
time in the morning and stand in front
of a mirror and say things like you are
beautiful you are great you are Savage
and I I actually you know I'm being a
bit unfair I don't want to completely
slate that because I've been told by
people this is really working for me and
as I say in the piece like I couldn't
get the words out I physically recoiled
doing it and if it's working for other
people maybe you know I'm not trying
hard enough
um if it's working for people who am I
to tear that down no really you know I
don't want to be I don't want to be too
flippant about it but I I found it
really difficult I didn't really
um equate that with with real self-love
and the questions that brought to my
mind were like you know when you leave
your day within a day you know when you
go out into the world and you actually
face its hardships and the hurdles and
the miseries and all of that are you
really better prepared because you've
you've done all of these things that our
culture is now telling you equate to
self-love and I'm not so convinced I
mean
I I think a lot of self-love comes from
resilience comes from you know people
making you question yourself doubt
yourself and actually that gut instinct
of pushing back like no I I have
something to say or I have something to
prove or I have worth
um and you know the way that we're
turning that into now this like very
extreme routine and it's everywhere
James like it's in my coffee shop love
yourself on the wall it's in my spin
classes which I adore but it's you know
self-care Sundays and
um is any of this really self-love or is
it just our sort of the latest way we're
trying to make ourselves feel a bit
better because they're like genuine
difficulties around us you mentioned
their adversity I think from what you're
saying it sounds as if like you can't
have self-love in a vacuum that actually
it's important to be based on something
maybe substantive achievement of some
kind or having overcome something as
well is there perhaps sort of a
vacuumness at the start at the heart of
all of this which is something you
presumably seem to recoil from the very
notion of you know James I think that's
really possible but I'm not really sure
where our self-love starts and and I
write in the piece I I suspect I'm one
of the many people out there kind of
looking for those answers
um you know I'm looking for ways to be
kinder to myself I'm not convinced you
have to have a big achievement or
something that society would say yes
this is objectively good in order to
have it I think it's probably
um much more personal than that and
actually that's what's so ironic about
this Cult of toxic self-love is that it
feels like you're constantly trying to
prove how good how pure you are you know
how consistent you are
um and I don't know my suspicion is that
has very little to do with it and again
I don't want to be too negative I know
in the piece like regular exercise has
been proven to improve your mental
health you know Reading Writing it's so
great for the soul it's not that I think
in and of themselves these are bad
things
um but there's this real attempt now to
again push back on perhaps what was like
brutal judgment in the past but that
over correction and is just like
overwhelming levels of self-care being
understood of self-love and I suspect
that practicing them the way that a lot
of people are practicing this is not
actually leading to pure happiness and
it's sustainable oh long term I mean how
many of these people start these
routines they may begin trying to
journal every day or so but you know
it's not necessarily fizzled out after
six months a year or so and also when
you do encounter some of those
adversities of life you know having
children for instance maybe working a
different job at different hours
actually some of those routines really
can't understand the test of time as it
were well this is it you have to cut out
all
in order to live
to live or a friend in need or basically
anyone in your life who might change
your routine you know after 9 pm say if
someone invites you for dinner or
there's you know any social event going
on this would be a really tough way to
live and and I do kind of note that that
um you know there's something really
wonderful about being taken in a
different direction even you know for an
hour or two throughout your day and I
would really struggle with the rigidness
that this kind of self-love is demanding
um and you said about culture earlier is
this something that sort of British or
American or is it just worldwide is this
sort of regardless of borders as it were
a cultural Trend look I think it's
something you're seeing in in countries
like the US and the UK and certainly
countries where social media is
prevalent I don't think it's only
Western but you also have to wonder like
what kind of lifestyle and what level of
prosperity you have if you are able to
do some of these things
um you know I suspect that actually a
lot of people posting may not have your
classic nine to five job that Demand on
their income or you know it might
actually be what what Tick Tock is you
know they might be getting money from
something like that but it strikes me
that this concept of a day before a day
I would really like to know what's
happening during the normal waking hours
from most people for those people are
they napping let's be honest here like
are they in that like ruling job that's
demanding so much of them because I
wouldn't have like a tenth of the
enthusiasm or effort that they have when
they get up at 5am
um I I really wonder where that comes
from yeah I want to ask you said you
tried this and physically recoil from
saying some of the words you're supposed
to how many days do you try to live like
this um well assistance
um James the affirmations only made it
two days and I I really was like I'm
gonna end up disliking myself that this
process continues I've definitely gone
through phases where you know I've tried
to you know wake up in the morning and
and and live this like very meditative
lifestyle
um for me it's not so successful but you
know again for others if it's working
for you just please don't pretend it's
easy please don't pretend that finding
self-love is easy and don't pretend that
it's so simple as creating a routine
well let me end by uh affirming you and
saying thank you very much for coming on
and delivering us a wonderful talk
thanks for having me
thank you for watching Remember to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and see
you next week
[Music]
foreign